[Music]
i am expected to have a big
it's a fetish that's out there
they expect it
three
two
one
go
[Laughter]
nobody nobody disagrees
yo
yeah i feel like it's a stereotype and
we know that stereotypes aren't
realistic but
i mean
personal encounters
i don't i don't feel like there's leeway
i feel like okay that one we're keeping
like that's what the general notion is i
think it gets into the issue of positive
and negative stereotypes and how people
need to realize that there is no such
thing because what you do is you put
people into a box where they're expected
to live up to a standard and i feel like
it's over sexualizing black men
i think there are certain stereotypes
that lead to better outcomes for groups
definitely i wouldn't say it's a
positive stereotypes definitely that's
what we call it you know if i was to
create a tier ranking that's what i
definitely think there are worse
stereotypes than better you know what i
mean that's what cause a positive
stereotype if it betters your outcome
it's a positive stereotype yeah okay i'm
not mad at that
i think the idea of why i wouldn't call
it a positive stereotype is more so
because the fact that it does create a
box that you have to live up to and if
you don't i'm not able to yeah then
that's like the negative downside of it
right so that's probably but i get what
you're saying yeah what you're saying is
right you know you should want to date
someone more for the pleasure physically
that they can bring to you and i know
i've talked to people personally who
would be like oh you're lucky you're
black you have a big member and i'm like
well i have other things to offer too
like i'm well spoken i yeah but we can't
[ __ ] the fact that you're spell well
spoken pause you know like i met a girl
was like oh you know i'm well smoking
like if we just trying to bank
imagine if she's well spoken while she
asked that you're digging your mouth huh
what the [ __ ] did you say
because you said no no no no this whole
conversation is a cake no no i said she
that's a g yeah she has her dick in my
mouth she said
so what i said yeah
if she has your dick in her mouth huh if
she has your dick this is gay i don't
care no stop talking about my mouth and
penis no it's her mouth
i said in how many languages
okay five the especially
[Music]
kitty hiding
okay let's go yeah you're digging him
out
it's uh
i think a lot of people watch a lot of
porn too and that that's where it comes
from like when you watch a lot of porn
you see you know these mandingos and you
know 10-inch monsters and i think it's
definitely reinforced by porn because
most people's simulation of that comes
from there so
our audience submit hot takes about this
group specifically that's not going to
be a hot tub i think you need to usually
listen take out the fire and put a
garbage can
but yeah let's go black men cheat on
their significant others far more than
other races that's not a hot ticket
that's just the real thing that's not a
hot tape
hold up hold up let me ask this okay
cause i think black men's uh
infidelities are just probably more
public but i'm sure if i went to latin
countries it's just as common but the
thing that happened is that it's in the
culture right we talk about it a lot
more yeah right when something we're
talking about like okay peep game i was
reading a paper about how the fact that
infidelity has a strong correlation
between higher levels of testosterone
which i think yeah yeah yeah and so like
you know that's the shag you take right
that was amazing though what when i said
what did you say
[Laughter]
so all you guys out there with high
testosterone just understand if you
cheat you're not an evil person okay by
really like the small dick tiny people
who when they cheat they're doing
something far worse because like there's
no reason
i'm just like where's the study
published did someone do some research
where they calculated numbers over a
given period of time the reason why i
was best kept it's more cultured than it
is strictly race-based those are my like
two theories which i don't think it is i
think that
everybody everywhere
i can guarantee you that if i looked up
the stats there's gonna be probably
higher levels of cheating here we go the
democratics are cheating in america
cheating definitely seems to happen more
amongst black folks and this according
to this whites and hispanics fall behind
men seem to cheat more in older age
women should at a younger age yeah there
are studies on this okay i wonder what
it's like in other countries but i'm
sure if they had robust studies does
that mean all black men no i think it
was only 22 percent of them reported
that so it's not even that high no but
it is higher than others because i don't
know the numbers that's what i'm saying
that's why i'm like true or not don't
disagree
you damn well no if this was a panel
black woman they all would have been on
the opposite oh yeah yeah definitely but
the thing is that they deal with black
to all the black women who feel some
type of way about this post a comment
right now this is for you guys black men
are attracted to big butts that's not a
hot tub that's not a hot tub you gotta
be one of the coolest talking about this
is a siberian take [ __ ] right okay
listen
take this take up to alaska
no it's north pole this is a kelvin no
no sub-zero this is california throw
that [ __ ] in space and let it float
this is that's one of the coldest takes
this is kelvin this is zero kelvin right
there what's kelvin it's minus 73
degrees this is the absolute zero i mean
there's nothing
biologically innate to like black men to
you know to like ass i think it ties
into hip-hop and the whole strip club
scene right now we are so far gone from
like the natural aesthetics of just a
natural person
these guys have no idea what they're
talking about black big butts have been
popular even in africa long before this
this whole cultural dances y'all didn't
invent twerking it's been around
you know what i'm saying like but then
again you know
americans sometimes they really think
data center thing yeah we started yeah
but but it was before that black folks
it was on the continent been a bit about
them it's a cultural thing yes but
latinos like black books too they didn't
always there was a time where you
fans because they were yeah they were
yeah yeah there's no doubt that hip-hop
definitely helped propagate that to the
main stream out of that but in terms of
like people of dark complexion being
into fat asses it's kind of always been
true
bro black people are funny they said bro
jubilee jubilee
wow
can i skip this take
corneas
homophobia is a big issue in the black
community
three
two one
go
a lot of us black men we will rather
be friends with the homie that
you know probably has a rape attached to
his name than the homie that's part of
the lgbtq plus community and i think
that that's something that you know we
got to work on as people because
my thing is i don't understand the whole
big phobia of okay what he decides to do
in his free time or behind closed doors
why does that bother you so much
basically i'm some slavery all right
that's what they that's how they used to
break people in and then break slaves
that were disobedient or running away
slave they would call it butt breaking
look it up that's yeah
but why do we still do it today that's
what he's asking there's a lot of things
that we still keep on doing today that
is from slavery right we'll have a lot
of baggage till from there and you know
we're very strong on religion and
religion doesn't help with that as well
there's religion there's also slavery
that doesn't help if you're in the
comments being like uh religion doesn't
lie that doesn't hate gay people get the
[ __ ] out of here i don't even want to
talk to you there's also something to be
said about the fact that a lot of gay
men don't necessarily want cis white cis
men
to be like you know like really close
friends with because if you think about
a lot of interest and again this is
gonna go towards stereotypes more than
anything let me ask you yeah when you
traditionally display more feminine uh
um behavior that's another problem okay
okay okay but again again
there is an overlap between that and a
traditional masculine environment that
is sports i agree right and so what i'm
trying to say is the traditional areas
where people may bond for example
gay men may not oftentimes feel
comfortable in those spaces i agree with
that but it's not because they're
feminine it's not because they're gay
that they're automatically feminine
because a lot i agree
the point i'm trying to make is this
right is that this is this is a
multi-layered issue yeah okay so you
have you have a port nope but i'm trying
to keep it a buck right because i think
it's important to look at these issues
like pause
so
you have one where it's like somebody
just don't want to be around gay folks
because they're generally uncomfortable
yeah and then you have another layer
where it's like unless you do certain
activities you may not encounter a lot
of gay folks right because i'll be
honest with you before i dance
i never encountered gay folks right not
commonly or not people that i knew
traditionally were right at least not
not in the gaming activities i was doing
or things like that not that i knew all
right
and then i think the third layer is that
the reason why i may not see those folks
at those environments is because they
may not feel accepted by those
environments but that doesn't mean that
i necessarily have a negative emotion
towards them does that make sense i
agree so i think that's why i was kind
of pushing back on what you're trying
and i also think it comes from religion
because
i don't want to get too controversial
with that but people are very religious
especially in the black community you
know christians and
and you know when you talk about the
bible you know they say you know
homosexuality is a sin
so
a lot of people have that great thing in
mind this is absolutely not right and
for a lot of people too they see when
they see a man they want to see a manly
man and they associate that with being
straight heterosexual men have a fear
that homosexual men
will treat them how they treat women if
that makes sense
i'm illusion and so they're afraid of
that treatment and i'm on somewhat agree
because i'm rather torn i think i've
lived a life where i'm around very
open-minded inclusive people so i'm not
sure how big of an issue it is in the
community see but that's what i'm
talking about that that
he's part of a very inclusive community
so there's no overlap because he's not
around yeah
i'm going to say something that's going
to be controversial go go ahead okay i
come from a dance background so you do
auditions you're around dancers all the
time around people for all races
sexualities and stuff like that it's
commonplace okay is that a hot take hold
up i've witnessed gay men be extremely
aggressive towards straight man yeah
i've had it happen to me yeah definitely
i checked my friend at the because some
dude was coming i was like bro what are
you doing and my friend was like yo
you're trying to get deck like what the
[ __ ]
so
it's not even a fear it's not like oh my
god i'm afraid it's just i'm not
interested and so there's an interesting
thing that he said where he's like you
guys are afraid that black men are get
treated the way straight men treat me
it's wrong when men do it to women yes
it's wrong when women do it to men
that's wrong when men do it to men it's
wrong when women do it to women too so
if i'm in an environment where maybe
flirtation is
encouraged or let's say i'm at a club
i'm not going to generally go to a gay
club do you know what i'm saying well
because your chances are slim to none
right so for me there's no incentive to
be around
i'm saying i have no reason to go there
has no interest to me no interest for me
i'm not mad at it i don't get mad when
people go i just i'm not gonna go in
those kinds of environments so um
to me it's not necessarily um yeah it's
just here's it's the weird thing where
it's like
there's an issue with like gay dudes
coming onto straight guys
the same way like you know how some
straight guys go up to lesbian women be
like i can turn you yeah there's gay men
who are hyper aggressive with straight
dudes or try to turn them they say yeah
absolutely and uh that's also something
that's yeah
it's not comfortable it's not
controversial it is for most people
because they don't encounter it
that's what you're saying you might say
that and i might say that because we've
been around dancers so we know yeah not
just dancing if you're not around them
you never see that kind of stuff i can
assure you i know some folks who would
lose their [ __ ] minds if what you
know i'm saying what i've seen happen
even for auditions
how many casting directors and how many
dudes who run these dance companies are
gay dudes i know personal friends of
mine who were said like send some some
racy photos or suck some dick yeah yeah
yeah that's that's the thing you know
it's not just straight dudes out here
being creepy with ladies there's gay
guys doing way worse
you know when terry crews was out here
talking about somebody grabbing his junk
it wasn't a straight man anyways i
digress and
aaron cruz a big ass [ __ ] too
and i gotta say this this is not to
encourage homophobia saying there's a
reason to fear them what i'm trying to
say is that just as a decide that's a
real take but i do agree that 100
homophobia is an issue in the black
community so i just want to make that
clear the black church sphere
homosexuality is often made out to be
the worst thing that you can be there's
almost nothing worse than being gay and
i think that's also where some of the
homophobia comes from to be fair though
that's not just the church that's also
within the book
that homophobia is one of the worst
things you can oh yeah it is so it's
important not to just make it sound like
it's the environment i can assure you is
not well seen period it's written yes
you can't be pro-black and date a white
person
three
two
one
go
i think really the issue with this
statement is for me
if you are a stand-up person and you
stand up on your morals and your
character it doesn't matter who you date
and i think a lot of the issue is a lot
of people get into you know interracial
relationships or they date white people
and they forget who they are and if you
are pro-black it doesn't matter if
you're dating a black person a white
person because you can date a white
woman and a a black woman and still not
even be for the cause so i really think
it's up to the person if they stand on
their morals or not so if you guys don't
understand where this comes from the
idea is that if you are a pro-black you
are four black families and if you are
four black men in your family so when
you want to create one and to continue
that lineage is to have a black partner
so you do the procreation now a lot of
people are going to be watching these on
the outside they're like i don't
understand what's all this talk about
preserving blackness listen indians do
it latinos do it people from europe do
it based off culture why people do it
you know what i mean it's very
commonplace it's just how happens that
black folks tend to have these
conversations online and in front of
everyone so for people who are not used
to this rhetoric they get confused but
trust me okay
the reason why that south asian girl
won't date you is not because you're not
attractive enough or whatever it's
because their parents want to preserve
that culture anyways i'm gonna just keep
playing it but that's the idea if you
have a kid with a white woman or an
asian woman and you're a black man
you're not doing the uh preserving or
you're not essentially you're just not
recreating black children i agree to a
certain extent but personally me i feel
like if you're pro-black you're
pro-black for everything like you're for
the advancement of the race you're for
businesses you're for everything black
so it's kind of hard for me to
understand how someone can be pro-black
and want so much for you know the black
culture and the black race and then
i'm not gonna lie i do like i look at
people differently based on who they who
they married because they didn't you
know you could be dating for fun i feel
like i look at people different based on
who they marry like
jordan peele childish gambino i feel
like i can look at them and be like i'm
not looking down on them i don't think
of them negatively but i'm like oh i see
and like oh okay i see like
because peop like black men that date
white women
it there's something different and
there's nothing nothing wrong with that
but you you know what it is like you you
oh okay child is gonna be you know i can
see that uh jordan peel okay i could see
that i think he's trying to say they're
a little bit whitewashed
i think that's where he was going with
it without saying it we're not saying
he's trying yeah you know i want to give
a shout out to the guy who went to the
far right in the previous question
because he's the only one who's willing
to offer a really good counterpoint
which balanced out the conversation and
had some logical consistency in order
for having these good dialogues you've
got to have people who represent on
different ends of the spectrum and
different ends politically so shout out
to him for that i prefer a light-skinned
partner to a dark-skinned partner
three
two
one go
i prefer a light skin see so when they
say i prefer a light-skinned partner to
a dark-skinned partner right i think a
lot of people don't recognize the way
which ways in which their subconscious
bias plays in so even if you may not
outwardly project that preference
subconsciously based off your choices
you or the what you desire you may have
that kind of preference anyways
don't play them colorism games over here
all right so the reason why i
subconsciously for me the reason why i
feel that way is you know growing up i
was always uh you know bullied for my
skin color i always felt out of place
you know i was always told i'm not black
enough and when you constantly hear that
you get beat down with that and
you know you doubt yourself and like
like i said i grew up in a broken home i
grew up in a foster care system so i
never it took me a long time to figure
out myself and for a lot of times i
don't tell a lot of people this but i
used to hate the way i looked i i was
like i don't like being dark skinned i
want to be light and i'm just being
honest but now i'm more comfortable with
myself i guess i have a question do you
think it's because
um you look at a potential partner as
lighter skin so that
your you know potential children or so
would be lighter skin so they don't have
to go with go through what you feel like
you went through
nah you know at the end day for me i
i'll marry whoever i i seem fit so it
really doesn't
to me matter about the skin color but i
will admit subconsciously i do think you
know when i see a light-skinned woman i
actually you know look a little longer
or i might linger a little uh longer or
be a little more interested i have a
question like do you at all feel like
you've become the person that bullied
you i really thought with my hair going
you know how my hair well i have a
question
what the [ __ ] is up with your hair
he was about to go there i wouldn't have
been mad if he did yeah
i think a lot of folks don't know
what it's like for people who have a
very dark skin complexion the kind of
comments they receive becomes very easy
to dislike your complexion because of
either media images or commentary that
you receive all the time how just
negative so um
i'm not surprised that there's going to
be some self-loathing that i've heard
this kind of stuff from a lot of people
i know
by then having this preference toward
lighter-skinned people as opposed to
someone that would look like you i will
admit yes
i will admit that and uh you know like i
said you know we just shooting a you
know shooting a realism so i do agree
with that yeah and i think i currently
go to therapy man what does charlotte
mean when you need him
yeah therapy can be going to the beach
or like
going out to eat or doing something that
relaxes you so physical therapy hold
on the [ __ ] did you say this time
yeah you know like getting medical care
could be like just stretching in your
room no it's like you know you know it's
self-care you need to get a martini and
then you know go on the beach and then
let the rays no
hold on
we have to be able to draw a line i know
what i'm saying it's open to
interpretation i'm here because i took
it as like sitting in front of a
therapist someone licensed to do this do
i do that no do i find other avenues to
relieve stress or whatever yes okay
okay i'm not mad at that but
let's just stick to therapy because
we're talking about therapists okay but
i'm not mad at that he made it yeah
but you can't mix up self-care with
therapy because it's two different
things yeah i've been in therapy for
quite some time um personal therapy
um just for myself just issues that i
have internally that i speak with
someone with on a professional level i
recommend therapy therapy is literally
the best thing you could possibly do for
me i find therapy in my faith you know
and uh i know there are a lot of people
who they look at like you know the
christian church specifically and might
not adhere to that but i think in recent
years uh the church has been adding more
professionalism to what therapy means
having these conversations you know for
some reason it makes you feel like
you're less of a man because when we
talk about therapy you know people like
really you're going to therapy but when
you think about it that's why a lot of
people have anger issues that's why a
lot of black men have anger issues
because you know they grow up a certain
way or they face a lot of challenges so
they'll not express it so or maybe they
can't afford therapy therapy is not
exactly cheap or accessible to life
it's it's pretty [ __ ] half expensive
um but yeah i thought it was a good chat
what did you think about the video
it's all right it was definitely better
than the other one yes but your hot
tastes gotta they're trash
they're not hot that's not what a hot
take means but you know what it's okay
because the hot take was only like two
minutes of the video yeah for the vast
majority they asked some decent
questions and they had
a panel that was diverse and would
engage with each other and challenge
each other this was definitely above
average for them better than the other
one oh hell yes
so i give them a shout out on that i
think yeah i think the whole the whole
dynamic is complicated but at least they
unpack some really good stuff um do you
have any other thoughts nah no what but
therapy well that's it from
the guy hope you guys enjoyed it
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]